[Music]
how is that guy how's it going everybody
it's Warren and we have a new albeit
very short TV spot for Black Widow now
this TV spot originally aired in India
and then it was posted to Marvel India's
official Twitter page now we have a new
scene of taskmaster in this video but we
also have some new information that
we've learned about taskmaster as well
now for those of you who may not know
taskmasters powers and abilities are the
ability to absorb knowledge
instantaneously and this ability is
linked to his muscle memory and it
allows him to instantly replicate the
physical movement of peak level humans
including superheroes so basically if he
takes a look at a superhero he can
pretty much mimic exactly what they do
unless it's a Thor's hammer producing
lightning basically any physical combat
technique or style he can mimic and in
this TV spot we see taskmaster just
soared through the air he's at least 10
to 15 feet off of the ground so it seems
like in this new scene of taskmaster
he's mimicking spider-man and what's
real interesting is that all of the
characters that we've seen taskmaster
mimic so far in the Black Widow teaser
trailer and in this TV spot have been
from Civil War of course we have him
mimicking Black Widow which is very
obvious at the end of the first teaser
trailer and at the end of this TV spot
he mimics Captain America with the
shield he mimics Hawkeye with the bow
and arrow and his movements even
resembled Black Panthers movements and
the teaser trailer as well and thanks to
some leaks we have recently learned two
major things about taskmasters Armour
one is thanks to a Funko pop leaked The
Black Widow and taskmaster Funko pop
figures have revealed that taskmaster
will have black panther claws it's very
obvious in this photo that he does have
these claws which makes sense because
taskmaster is going to be copying all of
the Avengers that he's seen to take on
Black Widow and most of them were there
during Captain America's Civil War at
the airport with the exception of Hulk
and Thor who he probably can't mimic
anyways and another one comes from
another toy league as you can see here
this new toy that is coming out of
taskmaster has him with his helmet the
shield and his sword but take a close
look at the helmet as you can see it
looks like taskmaster is going to have a
tech based helmet as we can see the
heads-up display in this picture
so Marvel may be taking a little bit of
a different approach with taskmaster he
could have the ability to mimic
everybody that he sees but perhaps a
little bit of technology is going to be
involved as well and perhaps this is
going to be Marvel's way of having
taskmaster mimic Iron Man
we actually saw Tony Stark in Captain
America Civil War uses heads-up display
and his AI Friday to physically fight
Captain America so Tony was able to
analyze the fighting style of Captain
America and used that against him in
hand-to-hand combat
it could be something similar to what
taskmaster will be doing he still
probably does have the ability to absorb
knowledge instantaneously however his
tech could advance this and take his
mimicking and hand-to-hand combat even
further and that's why he's going to be
such a threat to Black Widow in the
movie now again it is important to note
that he is copying many of the Avengers
that appeared in Captain America Civil
War because remember Black Widow takes
place immediately after Civil War Black
Widow is on the run but how could
taskmaster mimic all of these abilities
if he wasn't there well it's most likely
that some type of government had footage
of everything that happened and it's
very possible that whoever taskmaster is
working for could have been monitoring
Natasha and again what better way to
combat Natasha than to have her fight
essentially her fellow Avengers so
that's it for this new TV spot and this
new information about taskmaster let me
know what you think about the TV spot
and let me know what you think about
taskmaster having claws and having a
heads-up display like Iron Man does and
let me know who you think taskmaster is
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe with
notifications turned on to stay heads up
with everything relating to the MCU and
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
picking the winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
fluff
you